[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today David
what's going on in your world
dude I have a quick short
question would you recommend a person
who suffers from emotional spontaneous
shopping State out of the shopping malls
hang up David wait a second you don't
get to hang up yet that's too juicy but
wait a minute he knows the answer David
you know the answer
well what's your recommendation do I
just not bring as much cash into a
Walmart or a shopping mall or do I not
go at all do I uh well we're gonna dig
deep and find out how deep it is but
right before you dig I want to also just
make a connection with David I suffer
from emotional spontaneous eating so I
what type of things do you eat Ken oh
boy uh chips and salsa okay I go the
salty variety I don't want to make this
about me d I want to learn I'm going to
see if what you say to him about
emotional spending I want to know what
it me with with emotional eating I want
to know David what does this spending
look like are we talking about hey I go
to Target and next thing I know I've
spent $500 on a credit card is it I come
back because it's the Lexus Christmas to
remember and I bought my wife a new car
like how deep does this go I walk into a
shopping mall would say $400 my
intention is to buy one item and leave
but you know how a shopping mall is the
next thing you know you see this you
want that you may be with a woman she
sees this you want that she wants this
and the next thing you know that 400 is
gone I I I I totally get it but here's
the thing you came with 400 this this is
key did you go with $400 and you only
spent $400 or did you go with $400 and
you spent far more than
$400 okay that's that's a good I didn't
think about all that I see what you're
saying you see what I'm saying because
there's part there's
you actually asked a question be both at
any given moment I mean it depends I
mean not that I go to the mall a lot but
you know if you go over the $400 the
extra money that you're spending is this
you putting it on a credit
card yes okay here's what I would
recommend in general I think that we all
can can be emotional Spenders
celebratory Spenders I'm sad Spenders
whatever that thing that provokes you um
I'm a celebratory spender and eater by
the way um so knowing what those things
are like some of us it's like I like
spending money and these are my SP like
it seems like you have identified the
mall is it for other people it might be
HomeGoods for other people it might be
um I don't know whatever you know Bass
Pro Shops whatever it is right so some
of us know the key area is like if I go
in that store I will buy something so I
would avoid those stores also there's
some data out I just read this don't go
shopping when you're in a sad sad or mad
state of mind uh there's actually yeah
like it's people go out and and you
don't even have to be in the mall to
want to go buy something when you're sad
or mad that's right so that's that's the
other part so the first part is
identifying what is the store that just
I can't leave without spending something
and then the other part is identifying
what type of spender am I like I said
I'm a celebratory spender I get that I'm
a celebratory eater I get that you David
need to look and go what is the emotion
I'm feeling when I feel the need to
spend so that's number two now
practically speaking this is just me
when whenever somebody says hey Jade I
can't stick to my budget or hey Jade I'm
spending like crazy you want I just tell
people I'm like you need to take the C
the plastic out of your wallet and that
comes in two parts number one if you
have credit cards you need to cut those
Jokers up never to be seen again
and your debit card also needs to come
out of your wallet and you need to
replace that with a stash envelope of
cash that only gets you what you need so
David you're not the guy who needs to
keep $400 of cash in your wallet in you
probably need to keep 25 or 50 and that
gets you through the day don't take a
woman to the mall with you I know that's
right I got to add that don't take these
women out you can tell he's got an issue
with this David you take a lady of the
mall what happens to you
pal I
overspend he over spins he gets soft
like butter he's like I got to spin
she's just cuz she's looking at
something you want to make her feel
special David that's correct mhm that's
correct you need to tell her ahead of
time like Jade's advice show her the
envelope and say I only have $50 in this
cuz this other lady in my life named
Jade said I could only have 50 maybe
don't show her the envelope cuz we don't
want her thinking that will take care of
the lady problem it will that's what I'm
doing for him I'm helping him out
David's got a lady problem he does he
does but maybe don't show her $50 and
say this is all the money I have because
you find out yes I that might make the
pool shrink real quick no it'll tell you
whether or not she likes you for you or
the stuff you're getting her David true
I know what I'm talking about women
exactly because everybody has emotions
now oh no this is not on I'm not blaming
women I'm blaming you and your weakness
for
women okay well it happens that's right
I didn't get this cardigan you know
without some experience I know what I'm
talking about here you got to be careful
your Kryptonite that's you you're laying
it out there 100% are you let me just go
one one tab deeper do you think that the
majority of the spending that you do is
on other other people or other women or
is the majority of the problem that
you're spending on things that you're
buying for yourself 505050 50 it's 5050
so what I would say is reserve like if
you're dating around like if you're you
know swiping left or swiping right and
you're you know going out with different
ladies what is that a dating app oh okay
gotcha sry Tinder or whatever whatever
the are I'm not either but I I got my
ear to the pavement Ken so I know what's
going on you up to date if you're dating
don't spend like big bucks on these like
just a weekend date once you find a lady
and it's like this is my lady then you
can start creating like a a larger
budget for what you might want to spend
to wine and Diner do you have
debt I have uh about uh I'm about 100 in
the credit card debt but that's oh no
that's another conversation dve th000
you didn't tell us about that no 100 oh
okay just
$100 that's nothing okay yeah so we're
paying that off yeah it just look
telling you the envelope I like you but
this is how much I like you on this date
set yourself a clear budget get the
envelope clear amount of money in there
this is for dinner we're not hitting the
mall afterward is for dinner in a movie
we're keeping it simple we're not going
to extremes Ken no no concessions at the
movie but ladies okay it's poll time no
an pretzel in the mall James it's poll
time if you're a lady and you go on a
date and he shows you a $50 envelope and
says this is it this is all I got turn
on or turn off you tell us is this a
good thing are you like this is a
responsible male or is this a bad thing
I think it depends on how he looks I
really do cuz that would give if the guy
showed me a $50 envelope and said this
is it it would give me Uncle boo boo
Vibes and I would be like I don't know
about this guy I just he can keep it a
secret is all I'm saying just take me
out you don't have to tell me everything
right now create your free every dooll
budget today the simplest way to budget
for your life